oh uh now let's let's look at another
governor it's freeze frame
thanks control the technical
difficulties and we're going to bring
you back to
florida government is he smoking rhymes
now what is up with him would you blame
him
at this point i wouldn't good for him
he's like the guy that's probably doing
it but he's sneaking it at home
he starts to sneak it connie you don't
know i don't know he has one of the pens
yeah and he's like at the window open
or he holds it until the [ __ ] vapor
goes away he's got those really annoying
wives that you can't even open a window
in the house without two minutes later
she's like is there a window open
i feel like can i have yeah she sets the
alarm to beep every time a door or
window opens
you're like you're taking a [ __ ] and
you're in the guest bathroom and you
have the window open and you're like
and then from across the house she's
like is there a window open in there and
you're like
can i do anything santa's
in just a second but before we do we
want his eyes give you
a recap of what the governor of new york
said earlier today about the scandal
engulfing his administration listen
thank god are you really saying that
this is sort of the creation of a toxic
political environment that's existed for
several years in this country and in
this day
look uh look i told you dude
when i started doing my cuomo impression
that was the first thing i owned look
everything's because
this is cuomo right cuomo it's almost
like he's back there strategizing with
his assistants and he's like so check it
out right
so as we know i'm completely full of
[ __ ] and corrupt
so i'm gonna go out there and i'm gonna
do a whole thing right
and then it's gonna be worthless anyway
because then they're gonna start hitting
me with questions it's gonna get testy
what if i just blow through all that and
i just come out pissy everything is just
look
hey [ __ ] like just come out like that
and then that way i throw them off
it's just he go right to combative
it works you know it works for him in a
way because it's like okay
you know how this is going it's almost
trumpian in the way he is like
cuomo and trump are more alike than
either one of them will ever admit oh
yeah yeah they're the same guy
you know like i didn't do anything wrong
this guy is stupid
and it's fake news and he's literally
doing the guido
leftist version of fake news look these
facts
and then there's things that i did that
they're saying i did but then there's
also facts
you're like wait what he's trump he's if
he's trump with an italian accident a
powerpoint presentation
he's a greasier trump he's a trump
look he's a choice trump whose mother
makes better gravy yeah
i make the gravy uh
is the environment toxic
politically yes was this
happening last year also it's new york
is it toxic environmentally
yes yes is it toxic socially
yeah okay look it's a very toxic place
is our government toxic
and corrupt we have an entire island
that pete davidson came from that's just
a giant garbage dump for medical waste
we should have x-men uh uh
popping up throughout the city from all
of the radiation
and medical waste we dump into the water
unlike the garbage dump where his uh
pete davis's dad ended up ground zero
ironically enough named fresh kills
which come on man come on dude
last year with this toxic political
environment
yes uh
and do i think that's part of the
conspiracy theories that filled the void
yes
it's a conspiracy theory
it wasn't it was
it wasn't [ __ ] right-wing people that
were going after you
it was your own people it was lefty
democrats that [ __ ] blew the story
out
it wasn't project look man it wasn't
project veritas that went undercover
with a camera
it was one of your own aids it was like
yeah he told us not to say anything so
we didn't say anything
oh i'm sorry i killed people
where did you hear that q anon
actually the daily news yeah the new
york times new york times ran the
article
and they're on your side yeah it's fake
news
he just starts using it oh that'd be
hilarious fake news what are you gonna
do trump's getting all mad cause he
can't even be in public
he said uh milady is using my face
i'm suing him do we have any lawyers
left
are there any lawyers call rudy and
she's like rudy is almost dead sir i
don't
honey i can't get him on the phone
rudy's in the guest house he's taking
his pants off in
the pool house build the void yes
and look uh i understand politics
oh good for you yeah that's great
for i guess thank you it's our boy yeah
governor desantis joins us again
governor i'm sorry about the technical
problems thanks for coming back we
should still be crushing beers from
super bowl weekend
he should have showed up all disheveled
with a beard like hey gov are you okay
yeah we're just we've still been going
hard man
pirate hat it's the [ __ ] super bowl
talk i'm sorry
i'm sorry for cursing i apologize
um so when a politician big tech strike
him back
or box jersey at least she should have
worn bookstores i just want tom brady
to peek over should we go hey you want
tuck
wait what
still has the trophy in his hands and
you're like wow he stole the trophy huh
nah gronk super glued it to my hand when
i was sleeping
tucker carlson experience but governor
cuomo
says that what looks like a
fatal error caused by bad judgment
putting
coveted positive seniors back in nursing
homes
your outrage about that mind america is
is really just disinformation
and a conspiracy theory what kind of
explanation is that would you say
well look tucker we in florida we had
the exact opposite order we said
you can't the hospital send a coveted
positive nursing home resident
back into the nursing home because that
is the most vulnerable population
and you obviously would put them in in
serious risk
but we also did after the first few
weeks we established covet only nursing
unit so if you had
somebody test positive at a nursing home
they could be safely transferred and
isolated recover then go back
so that the other residents were
protected so we really viewed that right
death scientist
remember that yes ron is killing your
grandmother
how did he how did he get that
that name and [ __ ] cuomo got a
goddamn emmy
like it really blows your mind i i would
i would answer your question royce but
then we wouldn't even have a stream
elements
oh you're right don't say anything it's
better
it's better you don't you know the
sphere
when you're dealing with covid because
the fact of the matter is it's not
killing a lot of 18 year olds it is
tending to kill
people who are very elderly and very
very ill
it'll be fascinating and this is another
show but to find out why they did that
because everything you said
is rooted in the science but also in
common sense um
anyway i promise you you want to know
why tucker the reason is around mid
mid to late march we were all get given
models
saying you're not going to have any
hospital beds in five days every
governor got those models
i questioned the assumptions under those
models i didn't think that they were
valid and i said i'm not going to
conduct can
construct our policy around that but
even if i was wrong i would build more
beds somewhere rather than throw
uh these elderly people back into the
fire of a nursing home where they could
contaminate
and infect a lot of other people so it
was just an important judgment that we
were all called upon to make
and i think florida did it right and i
think obviously other states took a
different
different tact i'm sure yeah well the
one thing
death santa strikes again how many more
have to die before death santa
is [ __ ] removed from power pew